glaciers are natural wonders they're
shapeshifters wild and alive they hold
the keys to the secrets of humanity's
past of humanity's future
I'm dr. M Jackson
I am a geographer completely ologist and
National Geographic Explorer
for over a thousand years since
settlement Icelandic history economy and
culture has been inner woven with ice
glaciers have always advanced our zest
the rate their melting today is faster
than any other time
that's the story of ice it's not sissing
today we're doing terminal moraine
surveys of hatha-yoga between 1890 and
2010 nearly four kilometers of the
glaciers physical body dissolved largely
due to increasing air temperatures
well half my research focuses on
glaciers the other half focuses on the
people who live with pleasures
every year millions of people travel to
Iceland to see the ice before it's gone
it's one of the things I think a lot
about about what you to do if you're out
here every day when you're taking
pictures and even of your tourists
you're taking a record of what the
landscape looked like that day because
at 10 days add two weeks at a year it's
entirely different than many levels like
Sola India I've stared at Glacier
related businesses out of the coastal
village
as the temperatures increased I mean I
almost don't believe it and I work out
here I have to look at these images
so my cinders have told me that as
glaciers mount they mount money
I've seen an economic shift that has
reinvigorated this entire region it
allowed me unique access not only to
glaciers but to the people working with
them
for nearly a decade I've been working on
the southeastern coast of Iceland home
to Europe's largest ice cap that in a
yoga
I think Iceland is a living classroom a
huge opportunity to bridge the gap
between scientific data and human
stories have changed
[Music]
as the tourism industry booms fishing
the backbone of hub's economy responds
to glaciers in surprising ways
as glaciers recessed the land like a
sponge rebounds upward Huff is actually
rising coupled with sedimentation over
the coming years it's possible that
large ships may no longer be able to
enter and exit what happens to fishing
families then
everything I do focuses on trying to
make sense of the physical and social
changes
this is what is so powerful about
glaciers
glaciers make visible abstract concepts
make visible climatic changes human
history large timescales
make visible the stories were all apart
of the stories we ignore
the stories we act upon
if there is one thing my work continues
to show me it's the ice influences us
just as much as we influence ice
what happens to ice happens to us
[Music]
you